it'd be a pity not to recognize what's  at stake to go ahead and die stupid hate  and a fool it's a pleasure to see again  must be my lucky day  terrible time since seeing you some  putting odds up trains bring you home in  a box  the senator from the great state of  California  George Phoebe  [ __ ] son son outlier Deadwood days  are over  walk with the Future hearse won't take  long for he honors the rigors of his  putrid [ __ ] nature  [Music]  back my bid for buying utters property  and I will drop any counter action  against the [ __ ] moving us from the  center of town away from danger hate  running from himself the name for her  stew follow the law why the [ __ ] should  he be for you my job ain't to follow the  law and my job is to interpret it  I am NOT made for such complexity  [Music]  sketches  I'm coming for you marshal expect you  will senator listen my sense catches up  with  [Music]  you